When solving physics problems,
we have fundamental principles.
For instance, we have
Newton's second law.
And we also have an
energy principle,
work non-conservative equals
the change in kinetic energy
plus the change in
potential energy.
And many times
students are challenged
by-- do I use this law?
Do I use that law?
Why do I use one or the other?
Do I use both at the same time?
Can I get the same
answers, et cetera.
Now I want to illustrate a
particular category of problems
where we have some type
of circular motion,
and why we need to use
both of these laws.
So let's consider, let's go
back to our dome example at MIT.
And let's say we have an
object that's on the dome.
And now let's write out a free
body diagram for this object.
So we have our
gravitational force.
We have a normal force.
And here, let's just assume
that our dome is frictionless,
for simplicity.
So what you see here is that
the object is displacing
in a direction-- now here if
I choose r hat and theta hat,
and if I choose a
coordinate system where
I take my positive
angle theta this way,
that the normal force and the
displacement are perpendicular.
Now what that means is that the
work done by the normal force,
F normal dot ds is 0,
because well, we're
calling F normal equal
to the normal force
and that the normal force is
perpendicular to displacement.
So what that means
is all information
about the normal force is
not included in the energy
principle.
In fact, the energy
principle is-- the work
that's done is just the
amount-- this is angle theta,
so this is angle theta--
so the actual work done
by the gravitational force g
is the component of g mg sine
theta times the displacement ds.
So the only work
that's appearing here,
and this is conservative.
And so when we
integrated this work
and got that the work done
by the gravitational force
is minus the change in potential
energy, that's showing up here.
So the part of the force that's
in the direction of the motion
is giving us the
energy condition.
But we're losing all
information about the forces
in the radial direction.
So because also what we
need is Newton's second law
in the direction perpendicular
to the displacement.
Displacement is in the
theta hat direction,
so we need Newton's second
law in the radial direction.
And that we have r hat,
is we have a normal force
minus mg co-sine theta.
And the object is
undergoing circular motion,
so it's equal to minus
mv squared over R,
where R is the
radius of the dome.
This equation is
not at all included
in the energy condition.
You may say, well what about the
tangential Newton's second law,
which is mg sine theta equals
mR d squared theta dt squared.
But it's precisely
this equation that's
integrated with respect
to the displacement
and that gives us
our energy principle.
So in summary, the
energy principle
is the integration of
Newton's second law
in the direction of motion.
And we're completely
missing the application
of Newton's second law in
the direction perpendicular
to the motion.
Energy does not
account for that.
And that's why we
needed separately
to apply both of the
principles of energy
and Newton's second law
in the radial direction
in order to figure out
how to solve this problem.
Now this idea is true in general
when you have circular motion,
you need the energy
equation, which
is the tangentially
integrated Newton's second
on the tangential direction.
And you need Newton's second law
in the direction perpendicular
to that circular motion.